Wikipedia media and Academia are all
related to the question of
independent replication versus
prestigious citation sure so that the
problem is Authority and Prestige as you
see it from Academia and the media and
Wikipedia with the editors we have to
have uh
a mechanism where sort of um
the data and the reproducibility is what
dominates the discourse that's right and
so one way to think about this is I've
said this in
um I think I tweeted this or something
but Western Civilization actually has a
break last vacation emergency button
it's called decentralization right
Martin Luther hit it when the Catholic
church was too ossified and centralized
decentralized with a Protestant
Reformation okay he said you know at the
time people were able to uh pay for
indulgences like that is to say they
could sin they could say okay I sinned
five times yesterday here's you know the
equivalent of 50 bucks okay I'm done
with my sin I can go and send some more
okay this is really by their way out of
sin okay now people debate as to how
frequent those intelligence were but
these are one of the things he invade
against in the 95 Theses so
decentralization boom break away from
this ossified church start something new
right and in theory the quote religious
wars of the 1600s that ensued were about
things like where you know the wafer was
a body of Christ or what have you but
in part they were also about power and
whether the centralized entity would
write all the rules or the decentralized
one would and so what happened was
obviously Catholicism still exists but
protism also exists okay and uh
similarly here you've got this ossified
Central institution where you know
forget about I mean there's complicated
studies or difficult to summarize but
when you have the science saying masks
don't work and then they do
okay which everybody saw and this is not
like you know everybody knew that there
was not like some massive study that
came out that changed our perspective on
mask wearing it was something that was
just insistently asserted as this is
what the science says and then without
any acknowledgment the science said
something different you know the next
day right I remember because I was in
the middle of this this debate
um and I think you could justify masks
early in the pandemic as a useful
precaution and then later you know
post-vaccination perhaps not necessarily
I think that's like the rational way of
thinking about it but the point was that
such levels of uncertainty were not
acknowledged instead people you know
were basically lying in the name of
Science and public policy uh was you
know it was wasn't uh Public Health it
was political Health okay so something
like that you're spending down all the
credibility of an institution for
basically nothing okay and so in such a
circumstance what do you do
break glass decentralized what does that
look like Okay so
let me just describe what I call crypto
science uh by analogy to you know crypto
just like the Fiat science crypto
science right Fiat economics okay so
um in any experiment any paper when it
comes out right
it's you can sort of divide it into the
analog to digital and the purely digital
okay so the analog to digital is you're
running some instruments you're getting
some data okay and then once you've got
the data you're generating figures and
tables and text and a PDF from that data
right
leave aside the data collection set for
now I'll come back to that right just a
purely digital part what does the ideal
quote academic paper look like in 2022
2023 first uh there's this concept
called truly called reproducible
research okay
reproducible research is the idea that
the PDF should be regenerated from the
data and code okay so you should be able
to hit enter and regenerate it why is
this really important as a concept John
Claire Boo and Dave Donahoe at Stanford
20 years ago pioneered this in stats
because
the text alone often doesn't describe
every parameter that goes into a figure
or something right you kind of sometimes
just need to look at the code and then
it's easy and without that it's hard
okay so reproducible research means you
regenerate the PDF from the code and and
the data you hit enter okay now
one issue is that many papers out there
and science nature Etc are not
reproducible research moreover the data
isn't even public uh moreover sometimes
the paper isn't even public the Open
Access movement has been fighting this
for the last 27 years there's various
levels of this like green and gold Open
Access okay so the first step is the
code the data and the PDF go on chain
step number one okay the second thing is
once you've got so you can anybody who
is and that could be the ethereum chain
it could be its own dedicated chain
whatever okay it could be something
where there's a just the URLs or on the
ethereum chain and stored on filecoin
many different implementations but let's
call that on chain broadly okay
not just online on chain when it's on
chain it's public and anybody can get it
so that's first second is once you've
got something where you can regenerate
the code
um or the PDF from the code and the data
on chain guess what you can have uh
citations between two papers turn into
import statements yeah that's funny
that's cool right so now you're not just
getting composable Finance like D5 where
you have like one interest rate
calculator calling another
you have composable science
and now you can say this paper on this
especially in ml right you'll often cite
a previous paper in its Benchmark or its
method right you're gonna You're Gonna
Wanna scatter plot sometimes your paper
your algorithm versus theirs on the same
data set that is facilitated if their
entire paper is reproducible research
that is generated you can just literally
import that Python and you know then you
can you can generate your figure off of
it right moreover think about how that
aids reproducibility because you don't
have to reproduce in in the literal
sense every single snippet of code that
they did you can literally use their
code import it okay people start
compounding on each other it's better
science okay now I talked about this but
actually there's a few folks who have
been actually building this
um so there's use scholar.org which
actually has a demo of this like just a
V1 like kind of prototype where it shows
two stats papers on chain
um and uh one of them is citing the
other with an import statement there's
also a thing like called I think dsi.com
which is trying to do this all right
decentralized science so
this itself changes how we think about
papers and actually by the way
um the inspiration for pagerank was
actually citations it was like the
impact factor out of Academia that's
where Larry Page and sergeyman got the
concept out of right so now you've got a
web of citations that are import
statements on chain in theory you could
track back a paper all the way back to
its antecedents
okay so if it's citing something you can
now look it up and look it up and look
it up and a surprising number of papers
actually
um you know their antecedents don't
terminate or the the original Source
says something different or it just kind
of got garbled like a telephone game and
uh you know there's this famous thing on
like uh the spinach
um like uh does it actually have iron in
it or something like that I I forget the
details on this story but it was
something where you track back the
citations and people are contradicting
each other okay but it's just something
that just gets copy pasted and it's a
fact that's not actually a fact because
it's not audited properly this allows
you to cheaply audit in theory all the
way back to Maxwell or Newton or
something like that okay now what I'm
describing is a big problem but it's a
finite problem it's essentially taking
all the important papers and putting
them on chain it's about the scale of
let's say Wikipedia okay so it's like I
don't know a few hundred thousand a few
million papers I don't know the exact
number but it'll be on that level okay
so now you've got number one
these things that are that are on chain
okay number two they're you've turned
citations into import statements number
three anybody
can now at a minimum download that code
and while they may not have the
instruments and I'll come back to that
point but let me know the instruments
they can do internal checks the
benford's law stuff we were just talking
about
you can internally check the consistency
of these tables and graphs and often
you'll find fraud or things that don't
add up that way because all the code and
the data is is there right and now
you've made it so that anybody in Brazil
in India and Nigeria they may not have
an academic you know like uh Library
access is on but they can get into this
all right now how do you fund all this
well
good thing is crypto actually allows
tools for that as well Andrew huberman
and others have started doing things
like with nfts
um to funder lab I can talk about the
funding aspect there's things like
researchhub.com which are trying to
issue tokens for labs but a lab isn't
that expensive to fund maybe it's a few
hundred thousand a few million a year
depending on where you are crypto does
generate money and so you can probably
imagine various tools whether it's
tokens or nfts or something like that to
fund
finally
um what this does is it is not Q Anon
right it is not saying don't trust
anybody neither is it just trust the
centralized academic establishment
instead of saying trust because you can
verify because we can download things
and run them The crucial thing that I'm
assuming here is the billions of
supercomputers around the world that we
have all the MacBooks and iPhones that
can crank through lots and lots of
computation so everything digital we can
verify it locally okay now there's one
last step which is I mentioned the
instruments right whether it's your
sequencing machine or your accelerometer
or something like that is generating the
data that you are reporting in your
paper when you put it on channel okay
basically you think that's the analog
digital interface
we can crypto find that too why
for example in a Lumina sequencing
machine has an experiment manifest and
when uh that's written to there's a
website called ncbi National Center for
biotechnology information you can see
the experiment metadata
on various sequencing runs it'll tell
you what instrument and what time it was
Ron and who ran it and so and so forth
okay
what that does is allows you to correct
for things like batch effects sometimes
you will sequence on this day and the
next day and maybe the humidity or
something like that makes it look like
there's a ciscally significant
difference between your two results but
it was just actually batch effects okay
what's my point point is if you have a
crypto instrument
you can have you know various hashes and
stuff of the data as a chain of custody
for the data itself that are streamed
and written on chain that the
manufacturer can program into this for
anything that's really and you might say
well boy that's Overkill right I'm
saying actually not you know why if
you're doing a study whose results are
going to be used to influence a policy
that's going to control the lives of
millions of people every single step has
to be totally audible you need the glass
box model you need to be able to go back
to the raw data you need to be able to
interrogate that and again this is
anybody who's a good scientist will
Embrace this right yeah so first of all
those a brilliant exposition of a future
of science that I would love to see
um the the pushback I'll provide which
is not really a pushback is like
what you describe is so much better than
what we currently have that's I think a
lot of people would say any of the sub
steps you suggest are already going to
be a huge Improvement so even just
sharing the code yes or sharing the data
you said like off it's I think it would
surprise people how often it's hard to
get data uh is it like the actual data
or specifics or a large number of the
parameters not the you'll share like one
or two parameters that were involved
with running the experiment you won't
mention the machines involved except
maybe at a higher level but the versions
and so on the dates when the experiments
were running so don't mention any of
this kind of stuff right so there's
there's several ways to fix this
and one of them
I think implied in what you're
describing is a culture
that says it's not okay
exactly to like so first of all there
should be even if it's not perfectly
Unchained to where you can automatically
import all the way to Newton
it is just just even the
the act of sharing the code sharing the
data Maybe in a way that's not uh
perfectly integrated into a larger
structure is already a very big positive
step yes saying like if you don't do
this then
uh this doesn't count and because in
general I think my worry
uh I you know as somebody who's a
programmer who's OCD I love the the
picture you paint that you can just
import everything you know all
automatically checks everything my my
problem is is that makes incremental
science easier and revolutionary science
harder oh I actually very much just
screw that I would love to hear y'all
guys let me just kind of collaborate
sure
um why sometimes you have to think in
this gray area of fuzziness and you're
thinking in totally novel ideas and when
you have to concretize in data like some
of the greatest papers I've ever written
are they don't have data they're in the
space of ideas almost like you're kind
of sketching stuff and there could be
errors but like Einstein himself with a
famous five papers I mean they're
they're really strong but they're
they're fuzzy they're they're a little
bit fuzzy and so I I think uh you know
even like the Gan paper you're often
thinking of like new data sets new ideas
and
I think maybe as a step after the paper
is written you could probably concretize
it integrate it into the rest of science
sure like you shouldn't feel that
pressure I guess early on right well I
mean there's there's different each each
of the steps that I'm talking about
right there's like
the day of being public and everything
just that just having the paper being
public that's like V1 right then you
have the thing being regenerated from
code and data like the PDF being
presented from code data then you have
the citations as import statements then
you have the full citation graph as an
import statement so you just follow it
all the way back right and uh and now
you have that gives you audibility
then you have the off chain you know the
the analog digital crypto custody right
like where you're hashing things and
streaming things so you have the chain
of custody each of those is kind of like
a level up and adds to complexity but it
also adds the audibility and the
verifiability in the reproducibility but
you know one thing I'd say I wanted to
respond to that you said was uh that you
think this would be good for incremental
but not Innovative actually it's quite
the opposite I think
Academia is institutional and it's not
Innovative for example NIH has this
graph which is like I think it's age of
recipients of r01 Grants okay and what
it shows is basically it's like a hump
that moves over time roughly plus one
year forward for the average age as the
year moves on okay I'll see if I can
find the gif
what this why is this let me see if I
can find actually look at this movie
just for a second it's ridiculously
Powerful movie and it's 30 seconds
extension WhatsApp the name of the video
is age distribution of NIH principal
investigators in Medical School faculty
and it starts out on the x axis age with
the distribution and percent of pis
and from 19 early 1980s moving one year
at a time
and the mean of the distribution is
moving slowly approximately as Bellagio
said about one year per year uh per year
and this is 10 years ago one year in age
per year of time and notice how first of
all the average age is moving way upward
before you you know become an HPI second
is it's a court of guys people who are
just aborting grants to each other yeah
that's clearly what's happening you know
that's that's the underlying Dynamic
they're not awarding grants to folks who
are much younger okay because those
folks haven't proven themselves yet
right so it is this this is what happens
when you get prestigious citation rather
than independent replication the age
just keeps creeping up and this was 10
years ago and it's gotten even worse
it's become even more democratic even
more High bound right and so the thing
is the the structures that van of our
Bush and others set up the entire
post-war science establishment one thing
I'll often find is people will say
biology
the government hath granted us the
internet and uh you know self-driving
cars and space flight and so on how can
you possibly be against the US
government kneel and repent for its
Bounty you know and really what they are
the reason they they kind of they don't
say it quite in that way but that's
really the underpinning kind of thing
because they've replaced god with gov
they really think of the US government
as God you know the conservative will
think of the US government as like the
all-powerful military abroad and the
progressive will think of it as the
benign all-powerful you know like
nurturing parent at home okay but in
this context they're like how come you
as you know some tech bro could possibly
think you could ever do basic science
without the funding of the US government
has it not developed all basic science
right and the answer to this is actually
say well what if we go further back the
1950 did science happen before 1950 well
I think it did Bernoulli and you know
Maxwell and Newton were they funded by
NS SF you know no they weren't right
what were Aviation railroads automobiles
gigantic you know industries that arose
and they both were stimulated by and
stimulated development of pure science
did they were they funded by NSF no they
were not right therefore NSF is not
a necessary condition for the presence
of science neither is even the United
States obviously a lot of these
discoveries in Newton was before you
know like uh the I believe is for the
American oh let me find the exact
it's actually Less Old than people think
okay so Newton died 1727 right so I knew
that
um you know it was like in the 1700s so
Newton was before the American
Revolution right obviously that meant
huge Innovations could happen before the
US government before NIH before NSF
right
which means they are not a necessary
condition number one that itself is
crucial because a lot of people say the
government is necessary for the for
basic science it is not necessary for
basic science
it is one possible Catalyst and I would
argue that mid-century it was okay
because mid-century was the time when
you the middle of the centralized
Century uh 1933 1945 1969 you have
Hoover Dam you have the Manhattan
Project you have Apollo that generation
was acclimatized to a centralized U.S
government that could accomplish great
things partly because technology favored
centralization going into 1950 and then
started favoring decentralization going
out of it I've talked about this in the
book The Sovereign individuals talked
about this but very roughly you know you
go up into 1950 and you have mass media
and mass production
um and just centralization of all kinds
giant nation states slugging it out on
the world stage and you go out in 1950
and you get cable news and personal
computers and the Internet and mobile
phones and cryptocurrency and you have
the decentralization and so
this entire centralized scientific
establishment was set up at the peak of
the centralized century and it might
have been the right thing to do at that
time but is now showing its age and it's
no longer actually geared up for what we
have where are the huge Innovations
coming about Satoshi Nakamoto was not to
our to our knowledge a professor right
that's this revolutionary thing that
came outside of it
um early in the pandemic there was
something called project Dash
evidence.github.io which accumulated all
of the evidence for the coronavirus
possibly having been a lab leak when
that was a very controversial thing to
discuss right Alina Chan to her credit
you know Matt Ridley and Alina Chan have
written this book you know on
um whether the coronavirus was a lab
leak or not I think it's plausible that
it was
um
I I can't say I'm 100 sure but I think
it's at least it's certainly it is a
hypothesis worthy of discussion okay
um though of course it's got political
overtones point being that the
pseudonymous online publication at
project evidence at github.io happened
when it was taboo to do so so we're back
to the age of pseudonymous publication
where only the arguments can be argued
with the person can't be attacked okay
this is actually something that used to
happen in the past like you know
um someone there's a famous story where
Newton sold a problem someone said I
know the lion by his claw or something
like that right people used to do
pseudonymous publication in the past so
that they would be judged on part by
their scientific ideas and not the
person themselves right and so
um so I do disagree that this is the
incremental stuff this is actually the
Innovative stuff the incremental stuff
is going to be the institutional
gerontocracy the that's Academia where
it's like you know do you know who I am
I'm a Harvard Professor yeah I don't I I
think I agree with everything you said
but I I
um I'm not I'm not going to get stuck on
technicalities because I think I was
referring to your vision of data sets
and importing code sure and so that
forces just knowing how code works it
forces a structure and structure usually
favors incremental progress
like if you Fork code
you're not going to uh descent
descentivizes Revolution
you want to go from scratch okay so I
understand your point there okay
um and I also agree that some papers
like Francis Crick on the cloud streamer
there's are theoretical they're more
about like where to dig than the data
itself and so on and so forth right so I
agree with that still I don't um the
counter argument is
rather than a thousand people reading
this paper to try to rebuild the whole
thing and uh do it with errors
when they can just import they can more
easily build upon what others have done
right oh yeah yeah so the the paper
should be forkable but yeah so here's
what you know like uh you know python
has this concept of batteries included
for the standard library right because
it lets you just import import and just
get to work right that means you can fly
whereas if you couldn't do all those
things and you had to rewrite string
handling you would only be able to do
incremental things libraries actually
allow for greater Innovation that's my
account I I think you create I I think
that paints the picture I hope that's a
picture that fits with science it
certainly does it fits with code very
well I just wonder how much of science
can be that which is you import how much
of it is possible to do that certainly
for the things I work on you can which
is the machine learning world the uh all
the computer science world but whether
you can do that for all right you can
fix biology it seems to yes I think so
chemistry I think so and then you start
getting into weird stuff like psychology
which some people don't even think is a
science no
um just love for my psychology friends I
I think
as you get farther and farther away from
things that are like hard technical
Fields it starts getting tougher and
tougher and tougher to have like
importable code Okay so
let me give the strong form version
right so there's a guy who I think is uh
you know great machine learning guy uh
creator of actually Keras
um who just he disagrees with me on
Francois yeah he's been on this podcast
twice okay great so he just disagree
with him on a lot of stuff yes me too I
think we have mutual respect you know uh
follow each other on Twitter whatever I
think yes I think he does respect and
like you here's something which I
totally agree with him on and he
actually got like trolled or attacked
for this but I completely agree within
10 20 years nearly every branch of
science will be for all intents and
purposes a branch of computer science
computational physics computational
chemistry computational biology
computational medicine even
computational archeology realistic
simulations Big Data analysis and ml
everywhere that to me is incredibly
obvious why first of all all we're doing
every day is PDFs and data analysis on a
computer right
and so every single one of those areas
can be reduced to the analog digital
step and then It's All Digital then
you're flying you're in the cloud right
you put a date do you say how long or 10
to 20 years
arguably it's already there right and
here's the thing you you were saying
well you know you might drop off when
you hit psychology or history actually
um I think it's the softer sciences that
are going to harden up why
um one of the things I talk about a lot
in the book is for example with history
the concept of crypto history makes
history computable one way of thinking
about it is remember my Britney Spears
example right where Queen Brittany right
yeah okay so at first it's kind of a
funny thing to say a computer
scientist's term for history is the log
files until we realize that what would a
future historian how would they write
about the history of the 2010s
well a huge part of that history
occurred on the servers of Twitter and
Facebook yeah so now you go from like a
log file which is just the individual
record of like one server's action two
decade a decade worth of data on
literally billions of people
all of their online lives like arguably
that's why I say that's like actually
what the written history was of the
2010s was this giant digital history as
you go to the 2020s and 2030s more of
that is going to move from merely online
to on chain and then cryptographically
verifiable so that soft subject of
History becomes something that you can
calculate things like Google Trends and
engrams and stuff like that yes
beautifully put
then I would venture to say that Donald
Trump was erased from history uh when he
was removed from Twitter yeah and many
social platforms and all his tweets were
gone
I think someone who has an archive of it
but yeah I understand your point yeah
well as the flood of data about each
individual increases censorship it
becomes much more difficult to actually
have an archive of stuff but yes for
important people like a president United
States yes